[Music]
hey everyone its Johanna here this is a
long requested video on exercise plan to
gain weight for skinny women there are
many workout plans out there for losing
weight however very few on weight gain
and so I hope this will help you out
this workout plan is based on compound
exercises compound exercises are moves
which works more than one muscles in
your body and they are more efficient
and effective for muscle growth you will
only need to perform this exercises
three to four times weekly on every
alternate days it is important to know
that it is not in the gym that you
achieve growth it is when you rest and
recover therefore a full record day
should be followed by a rest day to
assure full recovery and muscle growth
spent no more than 60 minutes per
session overtraining will not give you
the results to gain weight and muscles
do not be afraid to lift heavy weights
because that is what you should be doing
to achieve results the question is how
heavy should I lift how many pounds well
it varies individually and varies
according to the muscles you work on the
best way to determine the right weight
for you is when you lift you should be
able to perform six repetitions or more
but no more than twelve repetitions of
an exercise if you can lift more than
cha reps then increase the weight if you
can't even leave six repetitions then
decrease the weight there are ten
exercises for this workout plan four
sets per exercise with 45 to 60 seconds
of rest in between sets for the first
set choose a weight that will be
manageable at 12 reps then rest for the
second set increase the weight slightly
to which you can only accomplish 10 reps
then rest for 45 to 60 seconds and for
the third set increases the weight even
more to which you can only accomplish 8
reps rest and for the final set leave
even heavy weight to it
failure at six reps the goal is to
achieve muscle fatigue where your body
will not be able to lift the same weight
or perform at the same intensity as
before
do this exercise plan for four to six
weeks and as you progress lift even
heavier weights and increase the set to
five or six sets so here are the
workouts squat stand shoulder width
apart with your toes pointed forward
because you are lifting heavy weights
always bend from your knees and lift the
weights using your legs muscles and not
your lower back keep your body upright
engage your core and slowly lower your
body as far as you can by pushing your
hips back and bending your knees then
drive with your heels back up to the
starting position and repeat tip your
knees should not go over your toes so
push your hips back bent over row keep
your body upright lower your upper body
by bending from your hips until it's
nearly parallel to the floor without
moving your upper body row the weights
upward close to your belly and squeeze
your shoulder blades together lower the
dumbbells and repeat push-ups get into a
push-up position feet close together
pumps in line with your chest slightly
wider than shoulder width apart
as you inhale lower your body as far as
you can in two counts
exhale and fully extend both arms and
repeat beginner start with push-ups on
your knees tip always keep your core
tight and body in a straight line do not
arch your lower back
this position is wrong keep your butt
down lunges stand shoulder-width apart
and take a wide step forward lunge up
and down by keeping your body upright
and both legs upended and 90 degrees
similar to squat your knees should not
go over your toes repeat on the other
leg for 12 reps each
chest press start by placing each
dumbbell by your side as you lower your
body use the momentum to lift both
dumbbells up in the air twist your wrist
and have your palms facing front
inhale bend your arms and lower the
dumbbells in line with the chest in two
counts exhale as you press the dumbbells
toward the ceiling
squeezing your chest muscles and repeat
show the press hold a pair of dumbbells
with the palms facing forward elbows
bent l's and dumbbells in line with the
ears keeping your body upright press the
dumbbells over your head lower and
repeat be careful not to arch your back
by engaging your core throughout the
exercise deadlifts stand shoulder width
apart keep your body upright and
dumbbells close to your body slowly
lower the dumbbells past your knees by
thrusting your hips back and bend your
knees drive upwards through your heels
pulling your shoulders back and hips
slightly forward tip keep your head up
and chest open throughout supported pull
up pull up is one of the most effective
upper-body strength workouts if you do
not have a pull-up bar at home like me
be creative and use a table or bar stand
by holding on the edge of a table arms
extended with your fingers pointed
forward bend your knees slightly pull
yourself up by engaging your biceps and
squeeze your back muscles at the top for
two counts slowly lower yourself back
down and repeat to make this workout
easier
bend your knees even more if you are at
the gym you can perform this on a
machine tricep dips place both palms on
a table chair or stepper with your
fingers pointed forward keep your legs
straight and body close to the table
inhale lower your body towards to the
floor by bending your elbows and ho for
two counts exhale extend your arms
raising your body upwards and repeat for
an easier version bend your knees and
bring your legs closer to your body to
easy challenge yourself by place
in both legs on another higher platform
either a table chair or fitness ball
spider-man plank get into a push-up
position bring your right knee close to
your elbow and squeeze your oblique
repeat on the other side for 12 reps on
each side aim to keep your body in a
straight line
throughout the exercise without arching
your lower back if this is difficult
start on your elbows here are five
additional tips first always challenge
yourself to more weights and more reps
but never sacrifice proper form second
keep a training Journal
this way you can track the weights use
and also track your gain in strength so
when you train don't just try to lift at
the waist instead think and feel the
muscles you are working on this will
increase the intensity and improve
performance fourth if you can train with
the partners so that she can act as a
spotter especially when you are pushing
through the few final top wraps and
finally exercising alone will not help
you to gain weight it is a combination
of good food eating a lot resting and
regular exercises if you think you are
eating a lot at a moment well you will
have to eat even more what you are
eating at the moment is only enough for
you to maintain your weight so eat more
please do watch my best tips for skinny
women to gain weight video for more
nutritional tips stick by it stay
focused and I trust you will see the
changes in your body eat rest workout
and you will start to grow all the best
for new fitness food and motivational
videos please like share and subscribe
to my You Tube channel and website do
you follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
you
[Music]